I've been keeping things light in the voicemail
segment at 2 1 9 2. David P.. We're continuing
that today. Take a listen.
I also bought a. Just wanted to know your
opinion on peanut butter and jelly sandwiches,
right? If you thought they were good ones,
you saw it. Maybe they weren't that good.
Yeah.
Beautiful question. Now, here's an interesting
thing, because I moved to the U.S. from Argentina.
Peanut butter and jelly is not a thing in
Argentina. So growing up, my parents had no
idea about PBS J. They would pack my lunches.
And so many people in elementary school had
P.B. and J. I had no clue what it was. Eventually
I was introduced to P.B. and J. And I like
it with the caveats that I don't want crunchy
peanut butter. I want smooth peanut butter
and only certain jellies, marmalade and jams
make sense. Orange marmalade in a P.B. and
J. No, absolutely not. Grape jelly, raspberry
preserves.
Now we're talking, my friends and a lot of
coronavirus P.B. and J I think is happening.
Joining me on the bonus show today, we've
got a lot to discuss. Pat will join me. We
will be back with a new show tomorrow if you
are not privy
to the bonus show.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.